Okay, you should be getting the idea now that the state charts are quite
powerful. There's lot's to them, like the class, diagrams, you don't have to
necessarily use all those features in every diagram that you do. How, in fact,
do these state charts relate to the class model diagrams? Well the way to think
about it is, that each of the classes. In the class model diagram,
has attributes, and those attributes form a state space. But
each of the classes in the state diagram could have it's own, state chart. And
that doesn't mean you're going to be building state charts for
each of the classes because, most of the classes have relatively simple states,
and are, perfectly well described by the methods manipulating the attributes of
that class. In th state charts, there's references to attributes.
Those are the attributes of the class. There's also
references to actions and activities, and those are the methods of the class.
The events in the state chart diagrams are going to correspond to signals.
A signal is a dependency in the class model diagram. You can use a stereotype,
in this case the stereotype is send, indicate that the move,
movement agent class, is going to send a signal, called the collision signal.
There's a dependency between those two two classes. So what this is saying is
that, as you're doing your state chart modeling, you have to make sure,
that it's consistent with respect to the class model diagram. That is,
the events have to be named, the attribute names have to be,
correct, the method names have to be correct, and so on.